this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by stitch fix
and harry's more on that later let's get
into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media
look make sure you subscribe to the
youtube channel the community's growing
i know you guys are watching hit that
subscribe
and uh the patreon community is growing
too it's the honeydew with y'all
doing this show with y'all out there
we've heard some crazy
[__] [__] i don't know if you saw
recently about the guy who went to get
heroin and had someone else's brains
blown all over his body
that's the kind of [__] i'm hearing out
there from y'all you got crazy story so
if you or someone you know
has that story that needs to be heard
submit it at honeydewpodcast gmail.com
and uh hopefully we get to do an episode
with you now you know i record here at
the santa monica music center so
if you need musical instruments or
lessons for your kids this is the spot
they offer
online classes right now during the the
pandemic you can go to santa
monicamusic.com use the code honeydew
they'll waive the registration fee and
give you a free lesson when you sign up
for a package all right
that's the biz right there now you know
what we do over here we highlight the
low lights i always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers i'm very
excited to have this guy on today
uh no doubt has some [__] stories for
us first time here on the honeydew
ladies and gentlemen welcome jason ellis
y'all
yes what's the honeydew my friend i've
been watching it for like a couple of
weeks now i'm like man you got
really really famous people on here you
sure you got the right jason ellis
i'm like wow that guy's huge [__] bad
show for you i guess
you gotta like fill the gaps it's a down
week bruh
this is a sponsor but i didn't broke the
other day like man
[__] must be [__] low
[Laughter]
well i'm stoked to have you on and we
we've been talking before i'm excited to
get into it but before we do please plug
everything you got a new show going all
of it please oh yeah the jason ellis
show is now a podcast so
uh the jason ellis show is available
where all podcasts are and it's on
youtube
i do a solo show called awesome world
and then we have a patreon
uh for the jason l show and for awesome
where we do two live shows a week
one of it like i do two of mine by
myself and then two jason ellis shows a
week
and then i have doesn't really matter i
have the tony hawk show and the mma show
on monday the first
ultimate friends conversation comes out
with myself and ellen joe band okay
but uh thejasonalis.com is the website
that shows all that stuff anyone wants
to go there or
at wolfmate on instagram uh
the wolf knives wolfknives store.com
that's my
clothing line i think that's really
that's your honor it's weird because i'm
in the middle of not really having a job
i'm not really sure who i'm supposed to
be plugging yet because i don't know
what's happening
you're a free man i think i'm on it
likes me still
uh like uh somebody gave me some liquid
death the other day but i don't know if
they
really like me i like the drink
[Laughter]
well thank you for coming on the tony
hawk thing you were telling me about
sounds so awesome i
you know i'm 47 i grew up idolizing tony
hawk on the skateboard
still dude his board is still the badass
of all the boards
and uh he has all the different ones
still did you know that
no like all the errors of him yeah
because i i asked one for my new studio
and he said which one do you want and i
you know i don't i skateboard but not
like
i'm not in the loop anymore and i'm like
i don't know like how many have you got
he's like
i got like every error and i'm like shut
the [__]
give me the [__] 90s one dude like
the [__] yeah and he's like boom
signed at my house so it's on the wall
[__] yeah my
those and apparently you can get those
anywhere his twitter is great because
it's like
it's honeydew stories it's all these uh
being just
we were talking about this i he'd be a
great guest on here an
icon in your [__] world and just
being [__] on by these people that
unintentionally like you kind of look
like tony hawk yeah i am not you're not
man
to say it that much that often that that
many people say you look like tony
hawk never just pulled the trigger on
your tony hawk
like what are the odds i don't know what
are the [__] odds the guy looks
exactly like him or
it's him it's weird that most people you
look like him
he's so many of those stories or you got
older
which is like no [__] what year is it
man he's in what his 50s now still
hitting the boards like that
he skates almost every day if the only
time he does if he has to go
do something but he has a ramp the
studio is going to be at his ramp so
that means i get to skate again
i got a uh uh mcl cadaver like knee
replacement about
six weeks ago and six months ago so i'm
my knee's about to
work again so that i could actually
write it down there body part in there
yeah wow what's that like it's [__]
awesome
i'm a zombie i'm a [__] zombie man
it's [__] sick zombie yeah
adam pot uh carbon fiber
wait there's that's a [__] what's the
one where you shoot
and it blocks the bullets kevlar i've
got [__] kevlar in there
in their knee yeah kevlar knee wait then
the actual
kneecap is kevlar no like the thing that
bonded the
dead person to me oh okay it's kevlar
so you know it's stuck in there man i um
did you skate the big ramps and [__] i
went second person to jump the mega ramp
you were a second oh [__] i went down
anyway and i were the
like he when danny built it he was like
let's go let's get out here
you are you're a different breed man i
um had a friend of mine that's an
engineer for the x games and i went to
minneapolis x games i think it was two
years one last year for sure because of
corona but the year before that
and he's like you want to go up to the
top and i was like [__] yeah i got
upside down elevator
yeah the cage elevator that i was
already like
this is making me nervous you know you
get they're going up left and right and
then i'm out
i'm out there on the side you know
holding onto the side just peeking over
and you guys are dropping in and going
off that [__]
i mean it's but how do you practice the
landing on something like that
how do you practice that he's done
because i watch guys like travis
pastrana
do flips into like foam pits and stuff
are you doing that at first to get used
to the distance no
never no no when we when when danny
invented the mega ramp i was on dc
as more of like the court jester who was
also good at skateboarding but harmless
enough to be
right alongside danny because if you
were as good as danny you weren't going
to be allowed to ride the mega ramp like
he was this is his thing rightfully so
he invented this crazy ramp
maybe there was like three other people
that could have jumped it but [__] him
he made it up
yeah but he knows jason's kinda good
he's ballsy but he's not that talented
so when he comes maybe jason will make a
trick it won't be anything that i do so
i don't have to sweat him and i'm
me and danny are friends but he'd been
there he'd built it and then he's like
gotta come out let's do it
and i was like [__] yeah i'll do it i
was terrified but i was also
uh it's a million dollar ram somebody
built a million dollars worth of
skateboarding utensils yeah
and i'm like and i'm like
it's like animal chin but but you know
to the point where it was so creatively
awesome
that i forgot that there was any pain
involved in it like i didn't
realize until the first time i went down
it
how much how i showed up with a
basketball jersey on cause i skate with
a basketball jersey
[__] looser i can move better and in
mega ramp
you don't [__] wear a tank you don't
show flesh
because it comes off when you fall there
the mason i just did
and it takes everything off it takes
clothes off takes pads off
i've melted my shoe into my toenail on
that ramp now
50 mile an hour that's what i was going
to ask you how fast you're going and
then
to watch these guys also they would mess
up but they would mess up
perfectly on their knees yeah that's it
there's a way to learn
how to [__] up and i was like god damn
so that's the last question because i'd
want to get in your story but what was
the actual distance you jumped
oh there's no there's a you're 50 miles
an hour it's a 50-footer and a 70-footer
so i only jumped at 50-footer
in but in mexico city i did a uh as
a 24 baxter there and the and the
quarter pipe is way harder than the gap
the gap's easy oh really yeah the gat
and especially for the gap if you go
straight the wind gets under your board
and it makes it harder
if you do a 360 either way when you spin
it cuts through the wind and it keeps
you level so it's easier to do a 360
than it is to do a straight air
oh so you do the three no problem
there's no g
forces in that because it's all sort of
the rollins in here
like if you're [__] pro you should be
able to go 50 mile an hour and stand
there picking your nose like
what the [__] is your problem why are
you wobbling what's wrong with you so
you so we can do that part
and then you land over the jump and to
me i've got motocross background so it
was easy
for me to put my mind in flying through
the air 60 feet because
dirt bikes do way more than that you
don't even have to be good to do that
but the quarter pipe when you're 220
pounds the quarter pipe is it goes
and then you get shot up like because
there's real weight like g's
hit you when you hit that against like
it's like a perfect it looks like the
perfect storm because it's
24 quarter pipe so you just hit that at
like
50 mile an hour and you go way past
where you usually go to the point where
you can't read
where you're landing is until you're on
your way back down so there's
terror there's a lot it was like a lot
of pressure to get used to it
but it was the greatest feeling i've
ever had in skateboarding so it was
totally worth it that mo
that jump just not the best trick i did
just when i had it down and i could do a
360 like [__] 60 feet
and land and go whack and just go
[__]
and sit up there yeah like like i like i
jumped out of a plane yeah you know like
what
and then there's all this time and then
does it slow down
oh yeah yeah so it feels like you're
flying yeah it's the ultimate to me
because
it depends on what you're into in
skateboarding skateboarding's for
everybody
yeah they're street skating i wanted to
go fast and i wanted to go [__] high
i wanted to grind as powerfully as
possible
that's what i wanted to do i wanted to
do body jobs where i smashed my [__]
board on the top of the
i was like aggressive guy i wanted that
felt good to me
but it wasn't it's not like that popular
but that's but mega ramp was right up my
ass
my alley that goes up later
we'll get into that later we should
probably get into that right now yeah
[Music]
well we were talking before the show and
and you
have quite a history so we said [__] it
let's just start
chronologically here so why don't you
jump into
uh very early on and what what happened
okay so it's not bad anymore it's great
everything's great but yeah there was a
little bit of a
thing i think my parents a little you
know my dad was 20 my mom was 16 when i
was born so they're a really young
total accident i think they partied a
lot and maybe a
maybe babysitter like made me blow him a
couple of times
and then i tried to rat him out and uh
but i thought it was my father
and then uh because i don't remember any
of this until i took a bunch of lsd
and speed at a demo a skateboard demo in
australia when i was like 23
and then i had an invisible friend in a
pool everyone left the pool
at the hotel and my girlfriend at the
time watched me have a conversation with
an invisible friend
who told me my father molested me no
yeah
so i don't know i don't i remember
seeing oprah shows going man molest
didn't people get people getting
molested
that is heavy i'm really lucky nobody
did that to me
turns out [__] people are shoving
[__] at me all the time and i was so
freaked an imaginary [__] blocked it
out until
all the drugs brought it back which
makes sense now because i've done mdma
therapy
and all this others i was gonna where
i'm like oh this [__] if you do it
it's gonna it brings back the stuff no
matter how hard you try to block it'll
come back
so there's a little bit of the
babysitter and the babysitter didn't die
my father's a very aggressive person who
i've seen like beat someone senseless
for cutting them off on the
on the road so [__] you with your son
and not die
tells me that maybe maybe he didn't do
it i don't remember for sure
but then uh i knew about these
real fast uh when i was a little bit
older
in a better house there used to be a
heat lamp that would come into the room
like a
a big round heat lamp someone would
carry it at night so it was
super dark and all i would see is the
heat big this big brown
radiator glow yeah so
people would somebody was on ba on my
back and i had my hands
under my pillow and they were trying to
do stuff and i would just pretend i was
asleep
and then uh i started to figure that out
this is from the mdma therapy where i
started to realize more about
what good this heat lamp because i
remember the heat lamp but i don't know
why then it escalated into
i figured out how to i went under the
bed and held onto the springs with my
fingers and my toes and i pulled myself
off the ground so i was under the
mattress and then that lamp came right
up to the bed
and i said please stop and the lamp
turned around and went back and in my
mind i went
i he went back to to his bedroom and
realized
that i wasn't into it and this was like
something that was bad i don't feel like
people knew
i don't think he knew how [__] up it
was like i feel like he was just so
horny and looking for anything and
didn't have
the outlets that people have today and
was and and had no
care for reproduction like it was just
like if it comes down to it
i'm coming you know i mean that that's
it which i feel
in my bones i have that you know where i
could just easily have sex with
absolutely anybody
at any time and be like yep sweet and
not you didn't
how's that i'm like i don't know good
bad good see you later i'm ready to go
old times
so knowing that was uh now are you an
only child
no i've got two half brothers were you
sharing a room at that time not just you
by yourself there
yeah which so this is the younger times
before they kind of he's 20 and your
mom's 16.
yeah okay yeah so when that finally when
i realized it was him that wasn't until
i was 40 and i went to rehab
because i was your father yeah i thought
i was molested by this
babysitter i said now the whole time
you're thinking it's
you knew the molestation was going on
but you're thinking it's someone else
this is the other thing so at the time
when i did all those drugs
and i and my girlfriend called my mom
and said
uh jason's you know saying he was
molested by
his father and she goes oh my god i
thought he forgot about that
forgot about so so now
so now i'm like what the [__] like i
thought just acid was [__] with me
what are you talking about you're saying
really [__] somebody really [__] with
me
so that makes it way worse and then
terrible i'm sorry and then
thought he forgot him oh my god so i
call her and i'm like what what
your dad died no he's alive oh yeah he's
dead now but
at that point i was staying at his house
i live in america and i stayed at his
house when i was in australia
so i get up in the morning and he's
there and he goes
do you think he got molested and i go
yeah
he goes you think it was me and i go nah
and he goes right
that's it never spoke again of it never
like who do you think it was
not one question this is your kid and i
did not think about that until later on
in life where i'm a dad
and now i and now i'm like wait you
would not stop the conversation
this is [__] oh my god
like people are gonna die right now what
the [__]
yeah go skate yeah it's like oh you lose
me all right we're good
yeah that was a bad tell as well and in
the end
so this when this comes out when i'm 40
my brother is not
my little brother passed away the same
year my dad passed away whoa
so that was really that was probably the
hardest yeah
[__] we've had to deal with so then my
other brother
who's in australia by himself with his
mom my stepmom
who's a nice lady she was mean to me
when i was younger
but i almost don't blame her like
because once again those are different
times
and if you were a stepmom you could say
you [__] hated your kid
it wasn't you didn't know that you were
doing stuff anyway yeah
no i feel like this is like everyone has
a little bit of therapy like everyone
the internet like you
you know if you tell a kid he's a piece
of [__] it's not good like don't
do that i think at one point some people
were like
make some tougher you know i mean it's
good for him that's what i think my
tough love yeah you thought was
happening so
when that first came out it was more of
this the stern show and they don't know
the stern show so they're getting like a
piece of
a piece of the story and then the book
has got stuff in there so now i'm
talking to them about it and they're
like well we don't think he did it and
i'm like i don't think you know
what dad was like because i know that
they didn't know before he passed away
he was doing live sex shows
secretly like he used to cheat a lot and
then in the end
once at one point he left was engaged to
a stripper who was
working at the same club that my
girlfriend was working at
get though so i knew all the scoop of
all of it and then he had a
half the house had hydroponics because
he was [__]
uh selling weed to get extra money like
all of a sudden now he's a [__] drug
dealer
none of us know any of this and he's
doing live sex shows now
what do you mean like [__] [__]
people in front of people also
not internet la actual live not live
stream no this is before that this was
he died in like 2000
okay one or some [__] so he would just
go [__] somebody in front of a crowd
apparently i didn't [__] know any of
this [__]
there was a couple of sketchy instances
it's gonna blow my [__] mind about
finding this [__] out wasn't this
mind blowing when you know the guy like
you know there was times
one time because i [__] i [__] these
his best friend's sisters all three of
them your dad's
yeah and he [__] two of them and i
didn't even like at one point i'm
working at his
uh uh his computer store and i go
guess who i [__] last night and he's
like who i'm like
jenny he's like jenny and i'm like yeah
she comes to the [__]
club like vip uh i got an emergency in
the nightclub for jason ellis and i come
to the phone and it's her saying
come out i've got attack i'm in a taxi
and some lady that's married to a friend
of my dad's
who is now wants to [__] me on the beach
on the way back to her sister's house
who i'm [__] right now so she cheated
on her sister on
with me so i'm [__] both the sisters
and i tell my dad because
we're at this we're we've never had a
relationship that's like
normal clearly yeah so it was a thing
where i was like
you're never gonna guess who i [__]
last night he goes you're [__] joking
me
i'm like yeah no why and he's like i'm
[__] going to dinner with her tonight
and i'm like
man my brothers were both my brothers
were alive at the time
my that's my brother's mom you're
cheating on you know i mean i don't
really like her
but not like that like that's not
[__] cool now i'm
not gonna tell leon st like you're just
telling me like where like this and
they're not which is not
it was just a bad run all the time and
then ever at one point
he picked me up in his speed boat he
bought a speed boat with the outdoor
engine
outdoor because he figured the outboard
was faster and he was trying to get to
100 mile an hour and right now it did 98
mile an hour that wasn't good he was
trying to get different
uh propellers to get that [__] extra
two cranks
[__] idiot dude so he's wasted and he
hits me up like get you know get on the
boat jay and i'm like what boat what are
you talking about
and i meet him on the shore somewhere
and he's there with this chick
who's it's even more it's like the
the sister that [__] me on the beach
her husband's sister
jesus so she's in the mix now with this
other dingbat that i don't know
so dad's [__] this other dingbat that
i don't know in a speedboat with this
other chick who's my friend
now his friend's sister i've already
[__] his wife
and now i'm gonna [__] his sister gee
and it's not my [__] i did not you
know wake up and go man
you mean i'm working my way into some
[__] family [__] here
so at one point i remember going flat
out on that boat and
yeah you don't have a family tree you
got a family [__] yeah
it was just all of that [__] man my
dad was a [__] machine
that's why i was trying to tell them you
don't like you still know you think it's
crazy he would [__] with me when i was a
kid like
he [__] everything man and i think the
other thing is
in these apparently you could hire him
to come over and [__] your wife
get the cuck [__] he was into that back
then apparently apparent mike
the co-owner of the business who ended
up owning it when my dad passed away
who i used to work with when i was a kid
to get the money to get
a ticket to america like that's how long
i've known this dude and now this dude's
the owner of my dad's shop
he tells me right after my dad dies
about this [__] like
that he was he said he called the number
at one point to [__] with my dad
to say do you do gay [__] and my dad was
like no don't do that [__] sorry mate
and then mick was like yeah you [__]
dave
and then they laughed but i totally
think that my dad was bi
there was a there was a gay bath house
next to the
the store and i didn't know this it was
called steamworks
so i walked past steamworks for several
years
steam works with the with glass but
blackboarding
behind the glass i'm like never thought
never thought
and then when i got when i started to
experience my homo side like all of a
sudden this comes out from
taking drugs i go to a gay nightclub and
someone goes oh the steam works next
thing you know i'm at the front of a
place where i'm like
that's my dad's store it's right like
[__] man and my grandfather for sure
melissa my dad this is my theory okay
all right
and he was a [__] i i guarantee this is
my theory i never looked at the books
but the steam works
the [__] ellis family were signing in
it's a [__] vip i reckon it was
[__] i reckon it's a [__]
40-year [__] day off secret gay off
just [__] generation to generation
i'm [__]
no one's looking no one's looking into
the scene works [__] it i'm not gay i'm
not gay like [__] get over yourself
he here's the thing about the hiring it
trips me i guess i'd be a bad
businessman because if someone's like
would you come over and [__] my wife
the answer for me is either yes or no i
wouldn't even think about
getting paid to do it you know what i
mean that's
[__] your wife i just i was like you
don't like you get the [__]
the internet's not out yet enough like
that but i think that
you but life is a guy wants to swatch a
guy and pretend
he's not gay by watch hiring a guy to
[__] his wife so he can play around with
the guy while it's happening i've been
involved in those like i've had guys
that are
in like sleep with my wife and then then
they're grabbing
the balls yeah [__] it they're grabbing
on your next thing you know they're
pulling it like they're pulling it out
of her [__] and putting it in their
mouth and i'm like
all right we'll [__] i guess we're
hanging out it's happened to me a bunch
of times man a bunch of times like me i
swear
the gaydar goes it's like when you don't
even know you when i was young
i didn't even know i had it it would
just all of a sudden i'd get into little
things where i'm like what
that's not what i came here to do but i
never
i got a million differences what
did you lose your virginity to a boy or
girl first
oh uh no i the first girl that i agreed
to sleep with
i was the last day of 1983. so i think i
was 11.
she had she was 16 she had hair on a
[__]
i was tripping i'll be yeah that is
trippy i didn't last long when you first
see
i don't know if i had to give myself
which is so
duty gonna be like have to rape myself
immediately for first sex
i would give myself a one because it was
like oh my god no one's got a great out
of the game i was freaking out i thought
i'd become a man
but you said something very specific the
first woman i
agreed to have sex with so let's let's
go back then because
uh when when did you first i i guess i
shouldn't even say lose your virginity
when's the first time you had sex
um the first time i sucked the dick was
when i was three it's a t-shirt right
we'll get that up in the merch store for
you somebody please
help me and buy my t-shirt the first
time i suck the dick i was
three yeah how do you i don't even
remember way bigger than mine
i remember four five yeah oh i don't
remember any i remember one thing when i
was three where i ate a cigarette
in the at a party and was like wow
those aren't tasty and then uh
somebody's saying you mean i'll suck
your dick
and then you suck mine how old was this
kid do you even know three or four
oh so you know you've got no there's a
guy doing that to me
how old is this guy it was a man
what yeah i just assumed it's another
kid an older kid a 10 or 12. no i never
never had sex with anybody my age until
i was like 18.
holy [__] a 30 year old man man how does
that happen
what do you mean i don't because because
there's [__] creeps and
people are my mom are you at a party or
are you
partying i think it was a neighbor who
came over and babysitted me who was like
sweet i'm gonna play this game with this
kid jesus christ
one of my mom's boyfriends [__] tried
to keep me at a party and offered me
crystal meth
when it was called speed and when i was
a kid but i was 10 dude
and i knew offered it to you yeah like
because i was tired no one to leave so
he came into the room because i was
watching tv and tried to offer me
he's like i could give you something to
you know get you going wake you up a
little bit
too promising
he said he [__] up he said but promise
me you won't tell
your mom and i'm like that sounds like
you're giving me drugs
that's good i'm telling you mom
immediately yeah
holy [__] there's some [__] dude i
remember my mom
with that guy [__] shooting up heroin
in the middle of the living room and her
screaming at him
and me seeing a dude shoot up i'm like
[__]
who would do that to himself that kind
of um
it was a good thing because i mean i did
eventually [__] up one time but
i really didn't give a [__] by then i
mean it was almost like waving a gun
around my face i was like whatever like
i was like i give a [__] i've done my
job so
what's the next incident then if you're
three then when so three
is then there's like five six i think
the end of it probably was about
um i mean i don't know my age i just
know that in the end i was
definitely a boy or not a man
but a boy that uh had voice that he
didn't wanted
uh this to happen anymore i also acted
out with my brother
he didn't even know that i had to tell
him and it's like why would you act out
with your brother
because someone was doing that to me two
people were doing it to me as far as i
know
and your dad and that center yeah so
they go you know there was a little
tangle up where it was like but it was
just the sitter
but just like that uh imaginary friend
told me from the get-go was it because
what he did to me
it's bad it's funny like all the scales
because there's two
there's these other women that were my
dad's um
wife's best my stepmom's best friends
who slept with me when i was underage
and it's not the same
because i was like [__] yeah i want to
[__] these chicks most of the all three
of them were pretty hot one was real hot
how old like 35 or something man and i
was like
15 and 16. whoa one night one of them
sucked me off in the bathroom and i came
out going what the
[__] was that and then this other one is
like hey come in and talk to me
and i'm and she's in the spare room and
i'm [__]
[__] my dad's best friend's wife
i guess they broke up but still i'm like
this is a person that at one point could
you imagine change my
diaper could you imagine your
ex-wife goes and [__] you no
no not at all exactly what the [__]
going on but but it makes me
a kid you think it's normal and then the
older you get like when i when i got
married to the
my uh my children's mother 15 or 16 you
probably feel like a [__]
king yeah yeah especially when i got to
be here
freedom man i was by myself and i was 17
in america it's the greatest thing
that's ever happened
greatest six months of my life without a
doubt
so multiple women also yeah but they
don't count as much but
it's like you do the damage of the of
the early ones and then you get to that
one and you go [__] i guess
i really do have to analyze that because
i think i treated women
uh in a disrespectful manner for a long
period of time
because i just thought that that's how
you roll like everybody just wants to
[__] right and then
like of course i'm not gonna go out with
you like well like oh do you love me
yeah sure whatever if you want me to
tell you that but i'm
we just [__] like that's all we do
because that's all i was
taught really not on purpose but
it definitely made my relationships
terrible terrible boyfriend terrible
husband
that i mean years of therapy otherwise i
would be for sure
single like for sure yeah my wife now is
she needs trophies for sure well good
for you for doing the work and putting
the [__] time in
right what um how old were you when you
got married
uh the because i've been married three
times oh you have
yeah yeah the first one was you're young
to be married three times
yeah yeah it's really stupid i was going
out with this chick for like seven years
she was so hot
like super like penthouse pad and [__]
and then she cheated on me with this guy
and
the person that told me was this other
girl that worked at the strip club
who looked exactly like my girlfriend
but younger she all of a sudden
befriended me and was like i gotta tell
you
[__] libby's [__] this other guy
and i'm like what really
and i'm like [__] annie was a kickboxer
which burnt more because i'm like i was
i thought i could kill anybody i'm like
i probably can't kill it
like hit him with a skateboard but i
don't know if that's gonna work
run over with a car i don't have any
moves yet
so that [__] stung as well
but then her and i got into it so i just
immediately jumped out of that
into this so wholeheartedly that i was
like we should just get married
and then we've had a full-on wedding
like castle
in australia like [__] 60 people or
something maybe a hundred i don't know a
lot of people
serious thing she hated um
her mom's used to hang out with chopper
you know chopper reed yeah yeah so she's
friends with chaparri kind of girl so
she's a smoking bong
still like bongs dude and she was when i
was married she was
i don't know 55 and she's like yeah i'll
be back in a second mate
and she'd come out like and i'm like
[__] you think you're
like like i'm i [__] smoke the ball
before i came here like
you [__] smoke weed she just didn't
want to share it no no but her
because of that my wife her [__]
daughter
hated it i so when we met i was high i
was on molly when we met
now i'm not letting smoke weed so then
it became this thing where
we got married and then all these things
changed like the story like where not
all women do this but when we got
married she was just like nah
i don't give a [__] what you want this
is how it's going to be because she'd
have two sides she was very cute
and she'd be like yeah i really like
things and stuff and they'd be like
listen here [__]
i'll [__] snap and you
outback man i know that [__] tone
that's usually
like a dude which is which also makes me
realize it was a father
she had a father thing on me she was
doing what my dad did
which [__] scared the [__] out of me
to the point where she used to beat me
it kind of escalated but every now and
then it'd be a punch of the face and i'd
be like
all right hold on what's the first time
she hit you
what was it like the very first time i
mean hit you like really where you were
like
no oh god i got it i never forget these
ones [__] uh so we lived in this
place in
in in carlsbad by the sea these weird
little shitty this weird little shitty
apartment they had a little stove or
whatever and we were doing blow
still and i think something happened
where i
were arguing in the end about something
and i was like whatever [__] get over
yourself
and she just went bam and just cracked
me right on the clothes first punch yeah
and i'm like
what the f i'm like don't no one [__]
does that i don't give a [__] who you
are you can't do that i'm [__]
getting the divorce
and she grabbed me by my [__]
like [__] like she's got a chunky
booty but like she's just a little
button
listen you [__] [__] you won't be
[__] leaving me i'll be [__] i'll
tell you when you [__] leave me and
i'm like
what are you that's who i am
yeah i'm like now i'm definitely i mean
you got to go to anger mate [__] your
anger management [__] i'll [__] kill
you and then eventually
those shots got to where i started to
figure out she would throw punches a lot
now
and if i duck too many or got my hands
in the way it would just keep going
so whenever it started to happen i would
just [__] drop my hands and put my
face in and let her land him
come on yeah because it was it would end
quicker that's it happened so much dude
that in the end i'd be like
and like and then you know because she
just wanted to get a good
like smack it you know i mean like
[__] dumb [__] and i'd be like
you got to be good with that right like
that one [__] cracked
and then it's usually good but the end
one was
dc flew me to aspen
uh you know jason pro skateboarder is
going to sign autographs at the [__]
bar
with some other pro athletes and she's
like i don't want to go
just be back by midnight i'm like okay
sure so i go to the bar
[__] you know i mean partying
drinking with everybody and i come back
at two
wasted and when i open the door she's
like what the [__]
it's [__] too and i'm i just
didn't i forgot who i was talking to
[Music]
it you know and i was like [__] you i
just said that
and then oh man i wasn't even looking
and then foot to the like foot to the
knots like
[__] straight kick to the dick drop
me to my knees
and then straight [__] up kick to the
face damn
and i'm this is before my boxing career
so i wasn't nude i was new to that whoa
so you know and it's like i'm like where
the [__]
am i and then as i'm starting to come
too
i start to feel this rattata tat on my
head she's still
hammering me i'm on my hands and knees
trying to like stay up
and she's standing in front of me
raining on me screaming christ
so i go into the living room and go sit
on the couch
and uh she comes in the living room
she's like what the [__] are you doing
am i gonna sleep on the couch
get in a [__] bed oh my god and this
is how much
this is how done i was dude i got up and
got invented you're crazy dude that'll
be scary
that's how many things i've gone through
i don't even know that guy
like that you idiot shame on you but i
went to bed
i woke up in the morning my pillows
covered in blood dude like i got [__]
work like a blood
black eyes and uh this photographer guy
i'll never forget it he's a really nice
guy i didn't like him that much because
he didn't skateboard or really like
he wasn't pro and it was back when if
you weren't pro i kind of was like
you know you don't get us and he was
kind of handsome and i was like what a
what a [__] so you know that
it was like a combination of that didn't
hate him just was like [__] kook
but he was in the room next to me
because dc paid for all these rooms in
this hotel
so he heard it and he's like i'm in the
bus the next day
and he's like hey man can i talk to you
for a second and i've got no [__]
idea dude and i'm like yeah what what's
going on
it's like hey man i was i heard that
last night i don't care
how big you are or what it is like
that's unacceptable
you cannot accept that you need to get
out of there she needs to go i took some
great shots
yeah he wouldn't get it that would have
been better if he had proof
evidence but it was still a thing where
he saw it and he told everybody else
because and then because i used to joke
about it and i think everybody thought
that i was joking so that one he did she
did that one and then she did another
one in public
in public in front of my roommate
uh i live we lived in a pro skateboarder
matthias
he owned a big house and i have rented a
room there with her
and this is when i'm back in that pot
smoking thing where i went to my
friend's mini ramp skating
you know she wanted to wait am i [__]
want some weed so smoke some weed and
then i got to go back to the house so
i'm like i'll put some shades on
i'm not smart man not very good at lying
that's why i play this game different
now i'm just like [__] gay
i'm weed all the time do you mean hate
me leave me
i'm not gonna hide anything so i walk in
she goes why are you getting sunglasses
out of my i don't know just [__] feel
like whatever i sit down in front of the
computer and start playing a video game
on my stomach
in front of the tv she's like take your
[__] sunglasses off i'm like i don't
need to take my sunglasses off
and matias is sitting on the couch next
to me and she's like [__] take him
off and i go
there you [__] happy sunglasses are
off
back to playing video games she jumps in
the air behind me
and lands on not on my head oh my god
she [__] she [__] kicked the back
of my head
holy [__]
and then started stomping me and as i'm
getting stomped i look up and i see
matthias running up the stairs
left me left me there to get destroyed
but that was the
when he told people and that other guy i
told people then that was when i had
some friends say
did you that you cannot take that you
cannot do that
so then that was when i was like i got a
so how did you
get the divorce how did you [__] you get
out of that without getting killed i had
an agent and a manager from being a pro
skateboarder so they helped me
um kind of do the the pay my the payment
thing like without a lawyer they said
you know we'll just give him
we'll give you that if you're okay with
it and she took that
and uh every now and then she came over
to
my house and tried to attack me or the
girl that i was sleeping with
so that kind of went for about maybe six
months my baby mama at one point was at
the house and she came in
she had the garage clicker still so she
came through the garage quicker
and i tell my watch i tell my girlfriend
get the [__] out of here she gets in the
car and as she gets in the car i go out
there and as the car's driving off
my ex is chasing her come on running
after the camera like [__] whatever
terminator guy [__] and i'm like
[Laughter]
i don't know what his [__] is looks like
he's pulling dicks oh
[__] she ran after the car this so then
she the car obviously is faster than her
on foot so she gives up turns around
sees me
yeah [__] a gut and i'm like what are
you gonna do she gets to the driveway
and just starts kicking my truck
cause i'm like well at least you're not
gonna hit me yeah and then she got in
the car and drove off so little things
like that and then
she fell in love with an actor in
hollywood and then i was free oh and
that was when
because i told her that i'd had some
bisexual
some gay encounters and then when we
broke up she
was at a wedding with my friend uh
carrie hart
and pink and she was telling pink and
carrie hart did you know
that your friend's a [__] nah and that's
when kerry reached out to me i was like
just so you know your ex is a [__]
idiot
it's the message he's spreading around
it's a day of joy
which also made me made a mental note to
myself hey jason don't
[__] tell anybody you've ever done
anything gay
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor stitch fix
online shopping can be daunting you
never know if things will fit
returns are difficult and you don't even
know what store to start with
this season let stitch fix do all the
hard work
stitch fix offers clothing hand selected
by expert stylist for your unique size
style and budget every piece is chosen
for your fit
and your life and it's the easy solution
to finding what makes you look
and feel your best try on pieces at home
before you buy
keep your favorites and send back the
rest stitch fix has free shipping
easy returns and exchanges and a prepaid
return envelope
is included there's no subscription
required try stitch fix once or set up
automatic deliveries you'll pay just a
twenty dollar styling fee for each box
which gets credited toward pieces you
keep and there are no hidden fees
ever stitch fix has styles and clothing
to fit any occasion for women men and
kids
they ship all over the u.s and available
in the uk
as well get started today at
stitchfix.com
honeydew and you'll get 25 off when you
keep everything
in your fix listen they sent me some
stuff i got
new shirts new boots i got a lot of
great stuff in there and you go on you
take this little quiz
and they tell you pick the stores i shop
at under armour adidas puma
i mean you know you can put banana
republic they got them all in there
everything's in there
then you tell them what you like they'll
say how would you wear this what colors
do you like what styles do you like and
you fill that out
and then they tailor that box or those
boxes and then they send it to you
uh again that's stitchfix.com
honeydew for 25 off when you keep
everything
in your fix stitchfix.com honeydew
our next sponsor is harry's now too
often we're choosing between quality
or a fair price with harry's you don't
have to choose they give you
award-winning blades at factory direct
prices when i first got my kit from
harry's you get a kit
the razor's got a good weight to it the
blades are great
shave smooth close i didn't get any
razor bumps
um you know it's it's a great product
for a great price and i'm telling you
you say oh listen for a limited time
right now harry's is offering their
starter set
plus a free body wash for just three
dollars
three dollars at harry's dot com slash
honeydew
you heard it right three dollars harry's
delivers a close comfortable shave at a
fair price
it's only two dollars per refill you go
to the grocery store they got the blades
locked up they got them locked
up behind plastic you can't even get
them and then when you get them it's
like forty dollars for some blades
harry's believes in quality so much they
went and bought their own damn factory
in germany so they could own
every step of the manufacturing process
how do they do it
harry's team combined a simple ergonomic
design with five sharp blades
they sourced their steel from sweden
they got sweden steel swedish steel they
got over there and they manufactured
their blades in their world-class blade
factory
harry's german factory is one of the
select few manufacturers in the world
that have mastered the technology
to create a gothic arch that's the gold
standard for razor blade grinding is a
100 percent quality guarantee
they stand behind the quality of their
blades so much they have a 100 percent
money back guarantee on harrys.com
all right for a limited time harry's has
an exclusive offer
for listeners of my show new customers
can get a hairy starter set
and a free body wash for just three
dollars
at harry's dot com slash honeydew that's
over 16
value for just three bucks you'll get a
five blade razor
weighted handle foaming shave gel a
travel cover and a travel size body wash
it's an incredibly great deal but act
fast while supplies last go to
harrys.com
honeydew to redeem your offer now
let's get back to the do so you never
had you never pressed charges you never
called the police
no none of that no no so you just took
the how long how long were you together
oh um maybe total three years
the marriage was maybe a year and that
was the the bashings ever since we got
married i'd say probably the last eight
months was wearing the bashings
but once she jumped to another guy it
all stopped for you that's when i got
released and you just didn't that
nothing's ever come back knock off
disappeared
never seen who i don't even know yeah
never heard of her
don't know what's going on so then how
do you uh how old are you when you get
married the second time
this is 30s so it wasn't that bad of an
idea to
uh this is uh after her i was like look
you know i smoke we play video games i
skate every now and then i do some rails
uh definitely not a father you know but
we can hang out
and uh she got pregnant and
i said uh you know whatever you want to
do
i respect it and i'm here to support you
i said
i know you know me and i know you know
that i'm not a good dad
so i'll give you that you know like if
all of a sudden you're like hey step up
to the plate and i'm not doing a great
job
i warned you
trust me it's going to be the greatest
father you've ever seen i said we're
going
to come in look i'm damaged man i didn't
even realize how damaged i was back then
right but i had a good idea that it
wasn't a good idea to have kids with me
so she was like i need to have that kid
and it was a bit of a lockdown thing she
did she really wanted me
back then and you know we had my
daughter which
i actually got married after you had
your daughter okay i got no
yeah yeah got married enough to have a
daughter and and uh
made the full commitment to fatherhood
and i learned from her parents
what it's like to be a [__] normal
person and
a caring human being yeah so i kind of
wasn't it was like hard times because
at one point i lived at their house to
try and save money
to get a house so that was not like the
glory years at all for me but i did also
watch
oh man it made me realize how [__]
uh screwed up my childhood was like
and i don't blame my stepmom was
definitely trying to hold it together as
a
because she's a human with consideration
for others
my father just plowed through life and i
think she just sort of back then you
just
went along with it back you didn't
really have a say
so um yeah those people
meant a lot to me and i and influenced
me a lot
which also made me realize you're
probably wrong
this is probably you a lot of these you
got a lot of damage
and you [__] idiot if you don't fix
it it's gonna go on your kids
it's a humbling moment and yeah it's not
only gonna go on your kids it's never
going to stop for you either and you're
going to pass it to them they're going
to pass it on and that cycle never gets
broken
the good thing i did immediately come to
the conclusion conclusion of was
they're not getting molested yeah you're
already awake you're already away by my
god
don't give me the [__]
i promise you [__] nobody did so man
so what happened i want to ask you so
this is a second marriage
when does drug addiction enter in and
during this
drug addiction's been around the whole
time the whole time yeah i was
but you said you'd smoke weed and do
some rails every now and then
you did mention you shot up once when
did you start okay so the shooting up
was
uh when i went back to australia um
how old are you when you do this man
this is the this is the uh the later end
of my skateboard career where i'm still
pro
i do sometimes i do waves of cocaine and
then i go well i've got to stop
but where there was definitely a period
there where it was just all the time we
never went out anymore we just got big
sacks and did blow around the table
and i remember thinking we're wasting
our [__] life i always when we got to
rock
started to rock bottom loser room i
would always go
this is not from i'm not going out like
this and i would make a big [__]
change and get back on track and
train and then do well in a contest and
then do one on the contest and then
[__] get a bunch of blow
and then go back to some [__] house
and dwell around it for
and get fat eating burgers in the
morning so it was always a cycle
but it would always get a little bit
better because i go man you really got
to pull that in same with alcohol
there was a time there where i would
just black out and just do anything
and and [__] everybody i don't even
remember what i did people would fight
me and i didn't even know we had a fight
someone's like i bet beat you up last
night i was like well congratulations
i hope you hope you mean hope it was
good for you because i don't remember it
that happened to me a lot because i just
and it wouldn't be aggressive i'm just
annoying i'm so annoying that some
tough guy would go i'm gonna beat that
dude up for being too happy
you know so then it was the
the heroine one was the worst one
because the coke i was like yeah
whatever i pulled the trigger on getting
sober with it
but were you doing pills and stuff first
or stop no i started with when i moved
back to australia
there's nobody to [__] skate with in
australia nobody's a pro skateboarder in
australia
if you're a pro skateboarder in
australia you wake up in the morning and
you go
nowhere nobody hey man wanna hang out
and they're like
what the [__] madam matt work
who are you yeah who is this [__]
it's tuesday
so it got lonely quick and then i would
get drunk go to bars
and then the drunk would would either uh
agree i'd be like let's get some molly
and then the molly would turn into go
down to some kilda
where there's all these hookers that are
on heroin
and they you know they get a [__] for
50 bucks
never burned them maybe once or twice
but it was more of a like a bj
thing and then they're doing heroin and
i'm got no friends so i'm trying to hang
out with them and they're like man i
don't really like
you know i just want to suck your dick
and get the money so i can get heroin
i'm like what about if we get heroin
together
so then they taught me how to chase the
dragon one time i chased the dragon in
vancouver
but i didn't do it somebody else showed
me so then i learned to do the foil
thing they gave me powder
so then i started to explain that yeah
so they give me the the white powder in
the little baggie
and then i'd get foil and i'd put some
of the powder on the foil and then you
the lighter underneath with the little
pen in your mouth glass pan
and just suck it up plastic pen for the
[__] oh really
dude i'm making this uh you're doing
heroin people
doing this this isn't there was not i
didn't tell one person
you guys heroin anyone she's pretty good
i like the gay [__]
and i gotta tell you i felt pretty good
you know
like i just didn't tell anybody that
story but
i think it's the only time you did it no
i started smoking it and getting hookers
started to be a routine so then i
started to you know get drunk go
out there at night and then find the the
hookers with the heroine and then it
escalated into
um you know i'm still getting paid a lot
of money to be a skateboarder and
and they don't know you know like
there's no contest i'm on
some sort of weird vacation i guess
being in australia
uh so i got a lot of money man so i was
like i'll get two hookers and get more
heroin
and i'm trying to find like hey i like
trying you know around i'm like well
this crazy
big blonde chick with huge tits i'm like
hey come over here
and then i get another friend i'll buy
you heroin they're like what
everyone thinks i'm a cop because i
don't know how to talk about drugs
because i'm just this [__] idiot that
is like i just i know what heroin is i'm
not the hr [__] you man just give me the
bag and let's do it
and then i was like let's stay like we
already shoot it up i was like let's
[__] shoot it out
and you had never done that i've never
done that before and i'd seen my mom's
boyfriend do it i'd seen my [__]
friend
do it to the to a girlfriend of mine
when they started dating each other
right in front of me and missed the
[__] veins
bleed everywhere and redo it i'm like
never i'll never
do this and then at that point
i just remember thinking where'd you go
we went to a house a room that was
the blanket rooms like i went into a
house that had rooms that were blankets
yeah
walls for blankets blanket walls so now
i'm in a blanket wall room pulling my
pants down while they [__] shoot me
up in the arm why are you pulling your
foot oh you because you're [__]
you're getting [__] too
and there's two of them yeah so now i'm
[__] one of them while they're
shooting me up
and i'm like all right good times are
about to roll
got everything's gone now i'm in a park
i just wake up in a park
up against uh the like the cage
yeah i don't i'm out i guess did they
rob you too yeah yeah
[Laughter]
what 800 out of it yeah no they yeah
they got eight hundred dollars and they
woke up in this park in some kilter
which is
[__] this park is so sketchy
and i'm unconscious man so i woke up and
i'm freezing because i'd obviously been
out there for a while
um and i mean they left me there because
i might have been dead or something so
when i woke up i'm you know i mean i'm
like okay you probably should have died
i feel cold like bad cold you're like in
the core like
i'm like i feel like i almost died
something bad happened you know like a
weird hangover
and that just i i was like okay
you now you know now you know and you
don't you're not
him you're not going out like that like
get the [__] up it was a it was a good
thing because it was
i felt so bad i thought you are
on the streets riling up
prostitutes that are not even into it
man they're on drugs
like you don't see that because of your
stupid mind and you're
in your upbringing of not understanding
like the culture or people's [__]
feelings or any of it i'm just like give
me give me [__] blah blah blah
am i cool yet like that's just my whole
[__] life
so i didn't realize i was doing any of
this damage but
that was a that was such a bad one that
even my
stupid mentality then it was like you
[__] idiot
like you've you're wasting your life
dude like nobody
there's all these friends you have in
california that you know that are living
this life and you're
you know i mean i'm a [__] wife's a
[__] and and uh i'm not as good at
skateboarding as i planned out i'm being
you know in the end i just couldn't
crack the
i couldn't beat a certain couple of
dudes and it's like not enough i thought
i was going to be the man
so i i hid in drugs so that one made me
wake up i was like all right that's
it no heroin again uh
and then you feel every time i quit
a certain drug then the other ones have
to come up
so the alcohol comes up to support me
not doing
heroin anymore or any cocaine and then
when i quit doing the drinking the
marijuana comes up
so there's like always been this little
float where especially when i get older
and i got kids i just don't drink enough
to
[__] my life but i'm [__] 49.
apparently now if i drink my heart will
[__] stop
because i've got some [__] thing a
heart problem that
is that right yes i might i have a huck
and go on an afib so i had an ablation
on it
and the doctor was like uh you're fine
man
uh but drinking can trigger afib so you
might want to just skip that from your
life
smoking weed's still good smoking weed's
still good in the world that's what i
said
i was like i'll just stay there yeah and
then that one works
for the pain arthritis all that [__]
yeah just
to be more tolerable and to appreciate
the day more
so i'm saying i have a lot of friends
that that her parents also that smoke
like smoking weed makes me a better
parent a better person a better partner
everything's big on the ps yeah all
right so what happens there you get
divorced
a second time yeah this one is uh there
was a
there was man okay i'll do it one time i
slew
the first time we broke up because we
broke up once and then i got back
together and we had our son
with the first breakout so you have two
kids yeah okay son and a daughter
so the first one god i'm so [__] bad
so the radio show i'm not doing i know
sex life is never
good and i'm a [__] boner man i'm
just like ah
come on everybody i i love wait wait
you're
350 pounds never done that before come
on
so this girl comes in on the show
because we're desperate for guests
and then she's like 400 pound lady who
has like you know shaq's eye goes up a
little bit
it's way worse than that and she's like
400 and she's a
a plus-sized pawn star or a model
i don't know what it is whatever so
she's in there and
we're talking and i i've i've got a can
i'm
i'm the kind of guy i don't know if i do
this at airports but i'm waiting for
[__]
i think of who's the second person i'd
want to [__] the most
in the whole not the first nah because
it's basic
first is easy that's interesting because
you've got cause
you start ranking people yeah i mean i'm
like [__] that one's like fourth
wait a minute wait a minute we might
have a we might have a third
a dark horse yeah like they come out of
nowhere and for me
i'll f like i thought that she was
really hot like i slept with china i
thought this really big girl was super
hot and i couldn't help it
chyna the wrestler yeah yeah that's i
mean she was a large lady
yeah big size yeah it's taller than you
right
yeah she's not as strong as me no no i
was hoping
i was hoping for yeah man that was my i
want to be disrespectful to bigger women
but i
kind of a part of it is like i would
like big weightlifter women they're not
usually into me because i don't have
they usually like weightlifter guys i
think but that's my
like my wife knows that if there's like
a big jack chick that's into me
i'm she's like okay go off you go
[__] because i would be so
one of those yolk ladies with the little
bikini that doesn't even cover the baby
i'm half a homo so i feel like it's not
that see now i'm being disrespectful
dude i feel like you're [__] a hot
chick dude you're the only guy i know
that would get turned on by a chick
that's
like their lats i like trans girls you
know to me like
i want to [__] everybody okay i'm like
wait you're a guy but you were born a
girl
i'm all about whatever my mom's like
jason really
i'm like we want me to lie like yeah i'm
into that too
all right big giant ones big jacked ones
just sounds crazy weightlift but that's
your [__] right there the weightlifter
chick
ufc chicks and and weights like they're
not they're different
bodies but they're still my those are my
ices okay any ufc girls that flirt with
me
i get like jittery because it's almost
like uh
i don't know what else there is i can
die with a smile on my face and i'm so
close
so back to this lady with the lazy eye
so gross
yeah so she's a nice lady man but she
was so gigantic but she was
you had a connection yeah and when we
did things
she consumed me like she was on top of
me and it was just like
and i'm like
it was like a different thing happening
it wasn't how did you get to that point
though how do you go
from she was like we should we should
meet up and have a coffee
and then i'm like yeah okay well there's
no harm in that you know and then she
was like we should go to my hotel room
i'm like you have a hotel room
she's like yeah two of them i was like
she might
no matter what this i'm bad on both
sides of this but
yeah so then that i guess because my ex
was real good at finding stuff so she
just traced all my
so wait you go back to the room is this
a one and done was this a
no you couldn't stop huh
you couldn't stop
how many times it was it always at the
hotel room yeah she had like a discount
at the airport hilton or whatever man
i'm gonna get [__] on
whatever uh it's so it just was just
always there like come on down to the
hotel
room and have you know i mean and how
did your ex find this out
she traced my calls and and schleich
would erase them but then she
like goes on there where are you always
leaving with food all the time
that got busted and then i and then her
father called me and said how could you
and [__] so
yeah that was but also like really
that's [__] up i felt like man you are
a real piece of [__]
i mean i i understand feeling that way
like she deserves to be to be treated
way better than that if my wife
cheated on me with a guy that was 500
pounds part of it would sure it's my
wife we have a kid together i'd be
devastated but the other part would be
like
there's something wrong with you you
know not there's something wrong with
500 pounds but if that's
you're just going to do it to mark it on
your list
i'm not marketing on my list but you
said i haven't done that before yeah
there's that
i do have that in my life yeah
when i slept with china i wanted to i'm
into it if there's nobody around and
nobody knows tomorrow i'm in
that's what the difference is i don't
[__] for what your opinion is like
if you're gonna frown upon me because of
the people that i've had sex with
i'm gonna keep [__] them and you can
keep frowning i'm not doing the other
way around i'm not gonna be like
guys guys i now just have sex with my
wife missionary with the lights off
praise the lord like [__] off dude like
this is my
[__] life my dick and my were good
everybody that we have sex with
is everyone's like hell yeah i am into
this
also so i don't see how anyone's getting
hurt in my game
except for you're married at that time
well these are these are the mistake
we're doing the mistakes here we are
we're highlighting these are rectified i
no longer sleep with 400 pound women
behind my wife's back
you can check my phone check my i don't
have
any [__] secrets i will say i told
the story on my other show people got
mad at me but somebody on grindr hit me
up and said that they wanted
me to boo in their mouth i want you to
[__] in their mouth yeah and i'm like
did you do it no but i asked my wife if
i could and she was like how could you
even think of it
and i'm like i don't i've i don't think
i'm into it but what the [__] human does
that
i just wanted to see if it's real i
think it's enough wonderful
i dated a girl for talked about this on
the show and on on ymh and stuff but i
dated a girl for a few months who kept
it together
one time we're we're having sex she's
riding me reverse cowgirl
and long hard work long nails doesn't
say anything
and just dry tries to shove a finger in
my ass
okay and i'm like whoa what the [__] i
was like spit on it
anything you know i don't mind you not
giving me a heads up but but
do it right yeah do it right yeah that's
the same as a vagina like you don't just
go [__] shoving things up there do
you no you gotta work with it
on it and then get going so i
it opens up a conversation that leads to
her telling me
that she wants to suck my dick while i
take a [__] oh the bumpkin
yeah yeah
would you do it though would you let a
girl suck your dick while she knocked
while you took a [__]
i don't even think i could get my dick
no i don't let's see that's the
difference i'm not
i don't want my my wife farts around me
i'm like oh my god baby like
that's not [__] cool you know i mean
like
and she gets off on her [__] because
i don't i'm like if you're taking a [__]
i don't know i would like just pretend
you don't [__] you don't shoot her
[__] or me [__]
involved in our sex life is a [__]
a no not even close what about back in
your wild days single day not a [__] guy
i piss on some gay guys
i'm glad somebody [__] finds it funny
yeah those guys are into that [__] the
first time it ever happened to me
i was at this [__] this is when i was
younger and still hiding it
[Applause]
[Laughter]
of gay guys before oh [__]
and admit that in a nice way oh man
okay go ahead the first time the first
time i didn't do it because i was that
was too scared he goes so you went to
water sports and i said yeah of course
because i thought he meant like what a
skinny surfing [__] like who is it man
and he's like oh cool you want me to
piss on you or you piss on me and i was
like
get the [__] out of here
no i'm going skiing dude what are you
talking about
but then years later from being in the
community
and getting different things out of
different
situations somebody's like hey man would
you do that i'm like yeah
i mean you ain't doing it to me but i'll
do it to you i do the pissing yeah
my wife and i piss on each other
sometimes too
dude you're so open i love it
i had a girl that wanted me to pee on
her i would only do it in the shower
though
yeah i just better i'm fine with you
piss on me yeah i rinse it right off
man seriously it's just your house is
just urinated
yeah like the kids come over and they're
like what's going on in the living room
[Laughter]
one time a girl peed into my i did a
ball sack
cup so i made my balls like a cup and
then i'll eat it into the cup
and then another girl drank the [__] out
of here dude i got video of that
listen i want to see it for a lot of
reasons
i wouldn't be gay to watch that you're a
ball bag in the [__]
piss and then yeah and then you brought
it over and just no i was in a jacuzzi
and somebody peed over out of their
vagina over me into myself get the [__]
out
they aimed it over and down we were
pissing on each other for hours it was
like
it was like a everyone just kept
drinking so there was tons of pee to go
around and every time someone had one
they'd get on the side of the pool
and start rocketing at somebody in a
different way
jesus i think it's on any fans account i
count
goddamn yeah yeah you're something else
dude
all right so third marriage
yeah when did you get married how long
you been married now um
i don't know like five years no only
three yeah three years we've been
together ten or maybe even longer now
because tiki was little i think we've
been together nine years so i've been
married three yeah there you go that
sounds about right
and you gotta sounds like you have a
good lady and you've also done the work
on yourself that's the thing
she was going to leave me she was why
same [__] thing every same reason
everyone else is going to leave me
well that's why i was somebody else
that's this is how it went down
i'm friends with benji madden and katie
with my wife who's
uh joel madden's assistant so we stopped
meeting each other even before when i
was married
we knew each other but she was a tattoo
chick so i need to steer clear of her
why because i want a [__] a tattooed
girl she's [__] hot dude
and she's covered in tattoos i don't
want to know [__] about her life because
i know me
like if she's like i think you're hot
i'd be like eh i shouldn't
i can't i couldn't stop it so
i just always talk to her in a
respectful manner to my wife
because my wife knew that tattooed
chicks and it was tattooed chicks
big chicks and black chicks any of those
walk in the room
i'm potentially already in trouble
that's how it went down
so i immediately had to go your wife
tattooed no
this this one yeah that's what i'm
saying the new
my new wife the last one the third one
yeah when she was in the room i had to
not pay attention to her because my wife
at the time
got it she knew that new to tattoo
people because i'm probably going to
cheat on them
or at least yeah and be something she
was very jealous too
she couldn't let me like have somebody
like me so that made it probably
more appetizing to get into that [__]
so anyway i meet her and everyone my
tattoos we got the same tattoos
he's like you guys [__] totally [__]
you guys and i'm like whoa easy man he's
like trust this chick's [__] crazy
i'm like this is you know
this is what you get jason like
everybody's like you're a [__] she's a
[__] madman you guys can [__] like
cut each other and [__] and i'm like oh
that does sound pretty kinky i i never
[__] played for the blood before
which
starts to come into play so we meet
we're [__] out of control straight
away we're [__] each other she's
[__]
teaches me that she slashes my arms with
razor blades and starts sucking blood
out of it and spinning
what yeah and cutting my chest and
sucking my dick and spitting blood all
over me like you know she's [__]
covered in tattoos
i'm like [__] you know this is
[__] devil sex man it's
[__] wild she's like restraining me
you know i mean like dang here
ran me here like it was just this person
where i'm like this is all
this is all the [__] i want like this
is like we should [__] and she's like we
know we should [__]
like it's it's her telling me we should
[__] i'm like that's
that's what i need in my life not
someone that it's like yeah all right
i'll hook you up again like i don't need
a [__] hookup you need to be in it as
much as i am and she was
and then the next thing was the gay
thing came out straight away
and i and i hid it from the other people
and whenever i did confess something to
it
all both other wives used it against me
both of them one didn't say it as much
because there was kids involved but she
was not
that was not a good piece of me to to
bring out i should have just not said
that it but this one with my wife if
she's in my apartment and there was a
uh cat what's the calendar that a trans
girl had given to me by being on the
jason ellis show and she's like you're
into this
and i was like yeah because i remember
thinking
i'm a piece of [__] to go out with like
don't
even make her think that you're worth i
mean just tell her the truth
because i figured at that point if
you're into trans girls
or you're okay with a dude blowing you
every now and then how are you supposed
to be
a a husband or a good boyfriend with
that
in your life like that's and i and i
knew it like a guy knows he's gay
that's what i am that's why i if i'm
gonna
have sex those things are in my life
that's who i
am it's what feels right to me so are
you bisexual or are you i'm
pansexual i think there's the what is it
pan yeah that's everything
yeah okay because i think do you have an
open relationship with your wife you're
allowed to have sex with men or whatever
you want
if you want whoa all right is she yeah
okay so i just get permission first you
have to get permission yeah i don't
phone and go hey just [__] somebody
that doesn't work that's not the way you
have to go hey here's the person if it's
a girl
they have to get a lot more info like if
it's a guy
it's this guy wants to blow me not now
because [__] pandemic but it used to
be
it used to be yeah because guys love
straight guys you know so it's just like
hey man
i'm like yeah man like why not
so now that's kind of out of the out of
the game so it's just a few regulars so
i kind of have like boyfriends
kind of not boyfriends because i don't
like go to the park with them and [__]
but
they're my friends the park is a big
hangout the park and the hikes
i don't like them i don't like hikes
there was one night this is a few years
ago
i'm with this girl we're on a date we
just want to old school make out so we
pull into this park well this particular
night we're in the valley
it's crazy [__] foggy like the kind
where you can't see
five feet from you right yeah and we're
in this parking lot at the park and all
of a sudden
here comes this car park pulls in single
guy gets out and just walks into the
abyss
another one same another one i go oh my
god yeah i bet you they're all meeting
here and i've been to one of those too
you've been to a [__] party i had to
someone tells me about it i'm like what
are you talking about i was right i was
like
you couldn't see anything did you go
deep in there and all of a sudden
there's like [__] 50 dudes all
waiting around
and all it takes all it takes is just
you i i
and then unzip your pants and it's on
holy
everybody everybody wants it in there
monsters dude it's like [__] monsters
i swear sometimes one there's this place
studs this is the scariest place in the
world right where is this it's on santa
monica boulevard
in hollywood west hollywood yeah it's a
movie theater
so my wife and i are [__] kinky as
you can tell we're like what is this
[__] theater and she's
gay too so well let's go watch gay
movie things or whatever so we go in
there it's [__] pitch black
there's movie theaters in the front and
then there's a big theater in the back
and when you get in there like you're a
[__] gay porn on a giant [__]
screen
but it's dark as [__] in there so i'm
holding my wife's hand walking in i'm
like
my eyes still haven't adjusted i can
barely see we sit down
and uh as soon as we sit down a guy
comes over
to try and suck me off and i'm like
babe what do i do she said come on let
him so i'm like okay so
right there they do yeah she's sitting
next to me so some guys sucking me off
two other guys come from behind in the
next
row of seats and a guy just flops it out
and puts it right next to my wife's head
yeah so like
i'm right here and it hurts here and the
stick goes
[Music]
but is it for her because she got
she got a hat on she's kind of like
trying to blend in with the gays
dude we came back because we thought it
was so [__] funny because i i
remember looking at god oh my god this
dude doesn't know
that you know i mean he's he's like
because sometimes gay guys girls and
barking up the wrong person it's like
vampire and garlic like they get they're
like
it's bad the next we went to the sex
store across the street
and bought those fake flaccid dicks like
and she put it
in her pants and put like a baseball cap
on and
that dude came over to suck it and says
he grabbed it he knew it was rubber
oh really but it's a fun place because
people come out of nowhere they'll grab
auntie and [__] i've had to like push
people off
in there i've never had that experience
but i've gone to when i first got here i
dated this girl from argentina and she
was into some [__]
and um one night she's like i want to
take ecstasy and rent a limo we're gonna
go to this club
in uh west hollywood and on santa monica
down a little bit
by the car wash like the little end of
boys town
and it was one of those clubs where
every night of the week it was something
different it was a building but monday
night it was you know maybe
um you know uh club night
or whatever and then it would be uh
burlesque and whatever on saturday
nights it was a club called
cinematic s-i-n-matic and it was a
you know type club in the front but in
the back
was full-on live s m shows oh somewhere
your dad probably would have hung out
back in the day he didn't do it probably
would have been in it i'd do that
so this is fun you should do it there's
these s m shows i'm into
some of it um but this one dude was
hanging like
[__] center picking up cinder blocks
from his ball bag and i was like yeah
i'm not looking at you i know that's
way too funny whatever you're in i got
to say cause when you're making it
you got to say whatever you're into you
can't be like oh yeah you can't judge it
can't say [__]
i gotta i gotta be like interesting
i can't say anything so yeah whatever we
took that team
but i was so [__] into everything
else
that i ended up walking up and getting a
seat and she came up behind me she's
like do you like what you see and i was
like we're going to have a really good
[__] time yeah
yeah it was hot yeah i think it's and
it's the kind of club you can go out and
[__] your girlfriend
right over in the corner and in the club
you know what i mean like anymore
yeah not anymore remember those days
yeah bailey it's a good thing about
brain damage
i don't even know what happened last
year anyway well listen
uh we're at that time and this has been
goddamn
[__] fantastically fun and
enlightening before we wrap up i'm gonna
ask you the question i told you yeah
going back now after all the [__] we
have talked about
what advice would you give to your 16
year old self
man keep your dick in your pants
probably right
but like i said i know i know 16 year
old me had to learn
the hard way so i think i would just say
hey man
like uh don't worry about it so much
it'll work out
i feel like that's really the because
all the times that i worried about what
was gonna happen
sometimes they did happen but it didn't
make any difference
sometimes it didn't and i just did all
that worry for no reason yeah and even
if
it does happen all the worrying before
it didn't help anything so to me
that's my biggest lesson is these days
i'm like if it's going to happen it's
going to happen
you know if the podcast everyone doesn't
think that it's
hot [__] i'm not worrying about that i'm
worried about doing a good show every
day
that's that's all you should be doing
that's it whatever happens happens
i'm ready for it you know um again
promote everything you want please
um yeah the jason ella show the podcast
downloads tell your friends all that
stuff like
and subscribe the youtube jason alice
show i do a
uh awesome world of solo show and then
the ultimate friends conversation should
come out
on tuesday with ellen jo ban all right
so i'm very excited about that because
our first
uh episode will be about conor mcgregor
uh smashing
dustin parker i was gonna ask you who
you thought would win this weekend i
think it's ridiculous
yeah yeah i think he sees it
i think when they're nice to each other
i think dustin's like you know thank you
food what are you giving hot sauce what
the [__] was it
dustin's got his own hot sauce that's
what i thought and they're talking about
connor's gonna
you're donating money i've never seen
conor mcgregor he's hot sauce
oh like they're [__] centered he's
doing that de la hoya [__] i don't look
i'd rather that than hear him talk
about somebody's wife and [__] yeah you
know i like that they're friends with
each other because
that's what people need to understand
mma is a passion
it's a it's an art form when all those
dudes get all angry and say that i feel
like
the average person thinks that you know
we're a bunch of violent
[__] which i don't think is the case
a lot of the time it's
i mean to me i don't fight angry look
how compassionate you are
yeah did you sense that from this show
yeah really
if you're not fighting them you're
[__] them i really look you kind of
you
we had to do molestation i told you you
didn't really want to
it's gonna just turn into a [__] off i
don't [__] look
i don't [__] all i do other stuff i do
yoga
and my pants are on the whole time every
time i go to the gym and do boxing i
[__] never show my coach you can
never do that he's never seen my dick
good that's good
no one's ever drank out of your ball bag
at a yoga class
[Laughter]
gonna roll with the piss oh man jason
thank you very much for coming on
uh i'm uh ryan sickler.com
ryan sickler on all social media we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
you